ми зі штейнмаєром пили колу і каву а
Лавров почав з візки Лаврова ж ніхто не
знає це ж Путін просто з іншим обличчям
це Лавров зі своїм лавровським обличчям
все погано російська реальність вона ж
ще шизофренічна А нам все одно нехай
буде ми душимо Росію доволі швидко Захід
не хоче задушувати осьі 50 відтінків
сірого Це не про нас ТН сьогодні став
сильнішим ніж він був торік по-вашому не
Полі корект скажу будь ласка ніхто не
хоче щоб Україна програла а Путін
переміг але ніхто не розуміє а що таке
перемога
Победа як веде переговори Володимир
Путін чому Індія і Китай незабаром
відвернуться від Росії і чим Сергій
Лавров шокував французького міністра
про це і не тільки про це в інтерв'ю
програмі в тренді у Києві розповів
колишній Міністр закордонних справ
України Павло Клімкін Павле Клімкін
Ласкаво просимо до програми в тренді на
дочвеле Дякую усіх
вітаю Павле скажіть російська
дипломатична школа вона формується
переважно через Московський держінститут
міжнародних
відносин як вирізняються російські
дипломати які ведуть переговори
делегація Лаврова Вони якось
відрізняються від німецької української
французької вони
закриті І вони не ведуть переговори
командою ми ведемо як американці німці
переговори
командою допомагаємо один
одному у нас немає такої формальної
субординації та формально
субордина там є свої ранги і розуміння
хто і хто проте всі працюють
командою ось До речі на нормандських
самітах Путін веде переговори
сам тобто ніякою російської делегації у
вузькому розумінні
немає є Путін та особи які його
оточують коли Лавров веде переговори
ніхто також нічого не говорить можливо
Лавров готується і Мабуть він готується
до переговорів але йому ніхто нічого не
нагадує Це дуже цікавий момент тобто
фактично він сам і німцям і французам і
нам є команда яка взаємодіє а от у Росії
все Ось так
вертикалка коли ви спілкувалися з
Путіним з
Лавровим я Путіна бачив тільки на
нормандських самітах А ще в Мінську Коли
це було у серпні 2014 року коли
обговорювалася угода про асоціацію а
Лаврова так Лаврова Я бачив частіше
Оскільки ми мали лише 15 зустрічей
міністерських нормандського формату тому
Лавров мені Сподіваюся
зрозумілішийсь який він Поясніть Лаврова
ж ніхто не знає усі бачать телевізійний
образ людина яка цілком очевидно
професійної точки зору тобто Розуміє як
вести переговори Розуміє як пишуться
папери розуміє техніку взаємодій і таке
інше А от де тут людина тому що за
телевізійним образом зовсім не видно
нічого тут людина яка у потрібний момент
вимовляє потрібні
гасла так от ви вже все й
сказали він у потрібний момент вимовляє
те що
повинен і в потрібний момент робить Те
що має робити я помню я пам'ятаю коли
Він приїжджав на Нормандські зустрічі
Іноді він мав завдання довго про щось
говорити він говорив і це тривало
годинами А іноді він клав рівно три
сторінки перед собою щось правив вже на
зустрічі зачитував ці три сторінки чи
дві а потім коли його запитували про
щось він зачитував ці абзаци знову лише
в іншому
порядку і він не мав Ані мандата навіть
про щось говорити якщо ви зараз
подивитеся що він озвучує це насправді
виконання завдання яке на нього повішене
нарізане Він не самостійна людина Я не
бачу самостійності когось із російських
міністрів Можливо вона є
відносною Хтось має більший вплив Хтось
має більший доступ до певних елітних
груп та Путіна особисто
але Лавров на сьогодні як на мене
перетворився на певного посланця Путіна
от він їздить на саміти на якій Путін не
їздить не знаю з якої причини боїться не
хоче якісь у нього ще є обмеження а
Лавров його репрезентує він фактично є
представником
Путіна і так його розуміють
усі так розуміють на заході його так
розуміють на незаході він викладає
позицію це Путін просто з іншим обличчям
Ні це Лавров зі своїм лавровським
обличчям який одержав якісь вказівки від
Путіна або не
одержав Я запитав про прояв людськості
Путіна коли вони себе як люди
проявляють адже ви ж із ними
спілкувалися на нормандських самітах не
лише за столом
переговорів а після зустрічі обід
вечеря Я розумію що ви не обіймалися але
там вони можливо проявляли себе
інакше Путін на нормандських самітах це
завжди Путін Я не знаю як він може
проявити
себе але він вдягає маску цю маску
принаймні на самітах де я був не
знімаєх бы
с насправді можу щось говорити досить
[музика]
відкрито особливо після переговорів він
може починати переговори з Шота
віскі Я пам'ятаю Берлін коли ми сіли у
бібліотеці розклали перед собою всі
документи я точно пам'ятаю що наш
французький колега Лоран фабіус пив
воду
ми зі штенмаєром пили колу та
каву а Лавров почав із
віски І от фабіус дивився на нього Я як
зараз пригадую ці очі реально понад 2
мтри таки з
жахом на початку переговорів після
переговорів все одно хто що п'є це інша
справа а потім ще один
шот але треба сказати що на якість
принайні викладу його позиції це
радикально не
впливалово мабуть якийсь елемент звички
чи самоконтролю
є останніє Ну візьмемо кілька місяців
для України Української держави
українського суспільства з погляду того
як складається зовнішня ситуація не дуже
вдало НАТО Ніякий практично підтвердив
те що було сказано у бухаресті у 2008
році глобальний південь як і раніше
нічого не хоче гарного зробити для
України заява саміту великої двадцятки
оминає тему агресії фактично відбілює
Росію в Америці насуваються вибори які
можуть привести до влади
ізоляціоністів яким глибоко байдужа
Україна усе
погано
А знаєте коли довкола все добре то
насправді потрібно задуматися Де ти
взагалі
знаходився Я не бачу щоб все було погано
Я також не бачу якоїсь явно негативної
[музика]
тенденції те що я бачу
це поступове дуже важке майже на рівні
судом розуміння У нехідному світі Я не
люблю це глобальний південь
тощо так от у цьому незаході розуміння
що якогось статусу кво попереднього його
вже
немає і треба якось висловати до
наступного А який він буде поки що
нікому не
зрозуміло я бачу що дискусії на заході
вони також дуже непрості Бо ніхто не
хоче щоб Україна програла а Путін
виграв але ніхто водночас не розуміє що
таке
перемога і ніхто не хоче колапсу Росії
бо що буде на її
місці Тобто це може бути така Вирва в
яку забере
багатьох тому накопичувати зміни це всім
дуже подобається а колапс у Росії ні і в
цьому парадоксально збігаються інтереси
західні та західні от китайці теж не
хочуть колапсу але ослаблена Росія їм
дуже
підходить що Україна може зробити для
того щоб Прем'єр Індії моді наприклад
сказав До побачення російським
енергоносіям або щоб китайці сказали що
ми більше не будемо закривати очі як
наші компанії допомагають Сірому
реекспорту або реімпорту в
Росію і теж не будемо купувати жодних
енергоносіїв тоді звісно у Путіна буде
дуже погана ситуація
не до кінця страшна але погана що може
зробити для цього
Україна усі шляхи обходу санкцій Вони ж
відомі для цього не потрібні якісь
суперспецслужби джеймси бонди все що
відбувається через Туреччину через Дубай
через Китай через центральну Азію через
Кавказ все відомо чи можна це відсікти
можна насправді в чому проблема у тому
що захід сьогодні не хоче перейти певний
больовий пор сзати А тепер ми душимо
Росію доволі
швидко от знаєте як у дзюдо в режимі
реального часу Такий задушливий прийом А
якщо це ми ж згадували з вами не захід
принципудава такий поступовий як
китайський дракон він же також удав він
так душить у своїх обіймах поступово тож
усе це можна зробити але не робиться
Захід не хоче
задушувати завжди готовий піднімати
ставки але ми хотіли б щоб захід
піднімав ставки сьогодні А краще вчора
піднімав ставки через постачання зброї
через те що Росія
ізолюється але захід він вже думає про
те А що далі і захід хоче так обережно
рухати зміни їх
акумулювати він думає що еволюція завжди
краща за революцію на жаль на заході це
сидить десь у у ментальній підкірці
Думаю скоро він спробує зрозуміти що все
не так
просто Давайте почнемо з того з чого ви
почали відповідати на запитання колапс
Росії якого боїться захід Україна його
не боїться та бажає правильно Україна як
керівництво Україна як
суспільство звісно тому що у нас
війна Ми живемо у цій війні 24 на7 ми
живемо оцією емоцією і для нас важливий
не колапс сам по собі для нас важлива
перемога а перемога для нас має дві дуже
прості
складові по-перше це звільнити власне
Україну у сенсі людей у сенсі територій
разом а по-друге зробити так щоб з
території Росії поки скажемо так у нас
більше ніколи не було проєктування
загрози
тому що як на мене Росія може
перезавантажитись і претендувати на те
що вона знову повертається у цей світ
якби ми його не називали цивілізованим
не дуже цивілізованим коли вона почне
сприймати Україну і нас як
рівних От коли Росія з погляду еліти та
з погляду
населення зрозумію що Україна
є ід че тальність історію все що
завгодно що це не частина проекту
Русского Мира як би ми це не називали А
до речі руский мир як на мене це
Віртуальна реальність назвемо це
красивим словом є ще таке гарне слово
доповнена реальність от Насправді те що
там є це Віртуальна реальність його нема
це створений Міф і місія про те що цей
міф треба
реалізовувати
А от Україна якраз можете не
погоджуватися не ви А хтось от Україна
якраз реальна з точки зору своєї
ментальності і ми маємо ментальність
дуже бінарну у нас завжди ви знаєте у
нас завжди добро зло Перемога Зрада ми
завжди чи так чи
так ми не маємо нічого посередині ось ці
50 відтінків сірого Це не про нас і
кольорова Політика це також не про нас
але це нам не завжди але інколи у
критичні моменти дуже
допомагає а от захід який дуже
раціональний який хоче бачити відтінки
сірого і мабуть захоче побачити після
Путіна якусь там я періодично це кажу в
розмовах мішустинську весну але головне
щоб ядерна зброя була під контролем щоб
якісь там банди не побігли біженців не
були потоки внаслідок якоїсь
громадянської війни Хоча я не знаю буде
вона чи ні у Росії а ви
До речі Вибачте багато хто в Росії цього
боїться вони серйозно кажуть про це як
про Вик звісно кажуть А от Ви в цей
момент кажете а нам байдуже Хай буде Хай
розвалюється Хай летить Захід у
сьогоднішній реальності
зрозумів що сьогоднішньою Росією на
перспективу жити на цій планеті дуже
складно і це є результатом
повномасштабної війни та
вторгнення
до
лютого
насправді на заході було чимало людей
які хотіли якось там таки Росію
запакувати крім того російська
реальність от я говорив про віртуальну
ну вона ж ще й
шизофренічна не ображайтеся я скажу чому
тому що вся Російська культура якою так
пишаються адже вона європейська за
змістом X століття
століття частина європейської культури
так
інакше вона не існує погодьтеся а от
решта набір цінностей реальності вона є
європейською А я вас запитую а які
українські цінності сьогодні головні Три
головні я вам одразу скажу це
свобода це
справедливість та це сімейні цінності
для абсолютно домінуючої більшості
українців є дуже багато речей за якими
люди можливо готові на компроміс
мпро але люди цінують свободу це завжди
було це пройшло через середні віки це
пройшло через козацтво це пройшло через
магдебурське
право Я завжди тролю своїх німецьких
друзів і кажу дивіться от У Києві є
пам'ятник магдебурсьькому праву а в
магдебурзі немає насправді адже це не
про
це тобто Свобода - це щось Що внутрішньо
є дуже важливим для української
ментальності Українець Не може бути
невільним якщо він невільний то він не
українець друге це справедливість як
вона
розуміється рівні можливості та
неможливість поставити когось над
тобою тобто коли когось ставили завжди
Це закінчувалося погано у будь-яких
варіаціях у будь-яких історичних
перспективах так і сім'я завжди була
важлива сім'я - це як частина
українського
мікрокосмосу тобто ця система цінностей
вона теж дуже важлива але без свободи та
справедливості при цьому демографічні
ресурси Росії вищі ніж в
Україні тобто ще кидати людей на фронт
можна до того ж як вам такий сценарій от
Путін якимось чином витримує цю
позиційну війну десь щось Україна візьме
десь щось
відвоює
а потім через півроку утомлений
американський уряд Джо байдена чи свіжий
американський уряд президента трампа 2
скаже треба робити у лабках мир почнуть
тиснути на президента Зеленського на
українське керівництво давайте
заморожуйте конфлікт робіть перемир'я і
таке інше не політкоректно скажу Будь
ласка Я вважаю що
війна Вона за визначенням
непередбачуванасиві ці варіанти як
камінчики так не
розставите все не
передбачите тому в який бік усе може
обернутися сказати дуже складно але те
що я точно знаю що в цій країні в моїй
країні немає того що називається глибока
держава Deep
State але точно є те що називається
глибоке
суспільство Якщо хочете тому мільйони
людей ніколи не змиряться з
тим що вони повинні знову жити в якомусь
розумінні з цією
реальністю російською
сьогоднішньою коли стоїш у
Михайлівському
соборі Тут недалеко в Києві на
похороні ти стаєш іншою людиною у
будь-якій іншій церкві теж на похороні
загиб на фронті Так ти інша людина тому
я не можу передбачити як будь-яка інша
людина якою буде
війна Але я точно можу передбачити що з
ією Росією з ією Росією ми не будемо
мати політичну та юридичну домовленість
якщо ми не
переможемо ми можемо зупинитись йти до
перемоги далі ми можемо зробити паузу
ніхто не знає як марціани прийдуть сюди
умовно
Так але ми точно будемо воювати
далі це завжди буде частиною нашої
національної ідеї та нашого
ДНК і це вже на покоління наперед не
зупинити тож може бути
тиск хтось прийде і скаже Ну от там
геополітика ціни там нафта туди сюди
інфляція
тут А от якще і я вам тут довго можу про
це
говорити якісь можуть бути дуже непрості
для нас
рухи Вони і зараз
непрості ми з цього почали з вами але це
суспільство і ця нація вже ніколи ніколи
не піде на компроміс із ією Росією що
буде далі ми не
знаємо а з іншою Росі
А ми не знаємо якою буде інша Коли я
побачу іншу Росію Не в сенсі політичного
проекту та назви яка існувала тоді я
зможу сказати чи зможемо ми якимось
чином говорити з цією
Росією але з цією ми вже точно не
зможемо і питання не в тому що от ви
кажете
колапс У нас є багато хто хто мріє що
Росія розпадеться і на другий день
прийде ща проблем більше не буде а моя
логіка в тому що ми маємо зрозуміти що
ми з цією Росією
робитимемо ми ж завжди будемо
географічно пов'язані Росія може
розпастись а на її місці утвориться щось
Що буде ще більш нас
ненавидіти умовно відпала там Камчатка
чи Якутія від Росії чи не знаю що там
все одно будуть якісь перетурбації
побачимо
А що Росія яка залишилася нас якимось
чином
полюбить А як на це можна Вплинути окрім
членства в
НАТО тільки ми через членство в НАТО та
ЄС насправді на заході і що цікаво в
Європі що цікаво в
Європі Італії Іспанії Франції які завжди
були трохи про російську культуру
Росію пам'ятаєте як Папа Римський
говорив про Петра го і
Катерину є
таке і вони розуміють що залишити сіру
зону в 90-х роках було фундаментальною
помилкою вони ще не дозріли до роботи
над помилками якщо росі роботи над
помилками За визначенням не може бути
тому що помилок не може бути А я інакше
ж диктатура не працює Вони завжди ж
мають
рацію А у демократичному суспільстві
помилки бувають і Ми всі робимо помилки
і готові над ними працювати І от на
заході вони ще не дозріли але вже
потихеньку думають Я вважаю що через
якийсь час вони прийдуть до того що
реальні гарантії безпеки через членство
НАТО та Європейський
союз тимчасові рамки які хочете
наступний
рік у наступному році захід зрозуміє це
не означає прийняття до НАТО але якесь
ментальне зрушення вони до нього досить
близькі світ вже частково розуміє що
складні домовленості в цьому світі де
міжнародного права немає система
перезавантажується повністю Бретон Вуд
перезавантажується ООН доведеться
перезавантажити інакше вона сама
здохне може й добре я не знаю думаю що
добре тому прості рішення а просте
рішення - це
НАТО в ЄС ухвалили рішення і в НАТО
також буде і насправді я це вже багато
років аргументую що і для Росії це
рішення також буде кращим Україна в НАТО
та ЄС звичайно вона отримає якусь
передбачуваність реальності і нарешті
почне думати про те з чого ми почали
нашу розмову У той момент коли в Росії
зрозуміють що з Україною треба говорити
на рівних він перезавантажить Росію в
майбутнє а інакше можна і надалі Бігти в
минуле Як ви вважаєте після того що
трапилося з пригожинським заколотом
ліквідацією пригожина але при цьому з
економічним зростанням яке є зарахунок
військової економіки постановки
економіки на військові рейки Путін
сьогодні став сильнішим ніж він був рік
тому чи ні він точно не став сильнішим я
не думаю що він став слабшим або
таким самим Тобто це інша
реальність по-перше всім відомо що його
помилки коли він недооцінив нас
недооцінив захід і переоцінив здібності
Росії вони
мультиплікуються тобто він схопив лопату
і надалі закопує сьогоднішній
режим це цілком очевидно
колись Росія була очевидна у Лізі
Чемпіонів геополітично але основа поваги
вона в цьому світі
інша погодьтеся Що захід по-своєму
поважають у світі є чималий
антиамериканізм алергія на Штати тощо
але повага є до китайців повага є а от
те що зробив Путін своїм вторгненням ці
залишки такої незрозумілої поваги які бу
що Росії Він практично
знищив тобто якась подяка до Росії за
допомогу від багатьох країн які
позбулися колоніального панування ті
самі індуси я пам'ятаю як вони говорили
в 2014 році і я знаю як вони говорять
зараз
как
го
дякую
вам